okay The Avengers um what the hell can I
say about this movie that every friggin
person on the planet hasn't said so far
it's a really good movie it's sort of
this miracle of a movie that it could
come together at all and that there's
been all this build-up to it using out
other movies to build up to this one
giant movie with all these celebrities
and these uh you know copyright hassles
to get all these heroes together and
they did it and they have this good
story and they have a good action and
good comedy bla bla bla so here's what
I'm gonna do I'm going to serve talk
about this movie in two ways I'm gonna
do one serve as you know a critic you
know sort of like just judging the film
as a whole and then one just sort of
like my personal take on it just sort of
how I feel in general have you talking
about from a critical standpoint it is
sort of this amazing movie in that it's
using like I said it's been building up
for years and years and it's a huge
gamble and it's a gamble that is and
will probably continue to pay off
because the bill that's been
unbelievable but also the response has
been unbelievable and for good reason
it's good characters characters are
already set up you know from other
movies that they were also successful
it's a good story well a basic story a
guy wasn't taking over the world super
hero stopped them very basic um and you
have some very funny writing talented
writing this is it's hard to get these
characters together and give them all a
story arc and give them all background
stuff and it succeeds you actually do
like these characters in fact there's
one point where a character does die and
I did find myself a tricot know like
legitimately pissed off and I'm sorry
like you know that's good that's that's
a good reaction to get um and the action
is really great as I'm sure you've heard
it there's no everyone's comparing it to
the Michael Bay films you know why can't
Michael Bay do this and I see why now I
first I was like why is everyone
comparing to this I see why not because
it's essentially sort of the same kind
of action scene going out where it's the
city and things are flying around and
people are jumping on top
other things and fighting and stuff like
that uh and this is really creative in
how they shoot it really action-packed
the stunts are very creative the
creatures identified a very creative the
ways they fight them are very creative
and to keep throwing new stuff at you um
and they keep having good funny jokes on
top of it and a lot of that comes from
these characters personalities which you
do like and you do enjoy so like I said
I sir feel bad I can't go into too much
more detail you know what that gave me
spoilers away and such uh because you
probably just heard it I mean everyone's
just going gaga for this movie and not
without due cause I mean it's it's a
good movie to go gaga over now let's get
to just what I personally like like just
what it what it sort of did for me I do
really like this we'll be in glad I saw
it but the reason I think everyone's
going really nuts for like really crazy
is the last 45 minutes the the last
half-hour to 45 minutes uh the action is
just so good and the comedy is so good
and it's just a ton of fun before that
it is a good movie but I'm sorry
watching this cuz I was going in after
all the build-up and I'm saying okay
this is good nothing great I mean this
is hard to put together you know but I'm
not like really invested I'm not like
what's gonna happen you know I'm enough
that's ugh did you know cuz like I said
it is just a very basic good guys stop
bag everything over the world story um
and the other thing that sort of stops
me just personally from like really
getting on the train of this was
incredible this was it but in a sense it
is and people that want to go see this
movie are gonna love it and really enjoy
and I really had a lot of fun the reason
I just personally don't get like that oh
oh you know the testosterone and stuff
like that it's cuz I didn't really grow
up with the Avengers um you know the
stuff I grew up with is like x-men and
bad
man even a little bit transformers and
so forth so that's the stuff like what
that's why I like the first Transformers
we it's like I did grow up with this I
was excited to see you know something
grew up with just so massive and so huge
so anyone that grew up with these uh
characters and stuff I mean you're gonna
be in heaven I mean this is a great
movie for you people and even those who
didn't you can follow it okay and you
can get into it okay and you can enjoy
the action you can enjoy the comedy and
is a comic book movie and it really
really soaks that in you know it doesn't
try to really disguise it too much if
I'm right when it started
AC Samuel Jackson with the eye patch and
the long Cohen at me night snickered a
little I'm like yeah okay this is
definitely a comic book movie you know
this is gonna be a little hard to take
seriously but you know you know question
it for long you get sucked in pretty
quick uh and that's one of the
challenges of comic movie and again for
for this to come together as well as it
did is pretty unbelievable for me
personally it's like I don't really get
behind something like wrong like that
unless it's something that I really have
like you know you could argue sir this
nostalgic attachment to so if if any of
the x-men movies were like this or this
big I mean I'd be like this just a great
Darren not the I off you know I'd be all
over it all right you like the first
Narnia movie which even I acknowledge is
not a perfect movie you know but it's
like I grow with that I read that and oh
that's so action-packed and they're
making it so huge and epic and I love it
even though there's of course problems
with it um so I guess that's why you
won't see me necessarily on you know the
train that everyone else is on and this
is the most epic movie and stuff it's
really really good uh and people want to
see the Avengers to see be really big
and really good that you're going to get
that and you're gonna love it and as a
movie critic I had to acknowledge this
is a very very good film any prompts I
have are very I guess kind of nitpicky I
I mean people are sort of saying well
this has taken the comic-book movie to a
new level in a sense it is it is more
from sort of marketing standpoint unless
a marketing necessarily but in terms of
what you can do with building up a movie
and getting characters a movie and so on
and so forth um like I said I don't
think anything quite like this has been
done with a film where you're literally
making movies just to build up to one
giant one it's not like a trilogy or
something like that you're literally
just making films to build up to this
huge one and it legitimately pays off I
can't think of a time that's really
happened where that was like the goal
you know the purpose of making these
other films on top of making money of
course uh but if I'm gonna nip ik at all
I mean I I'd say love it I I heard there
was about two hours apparently cut out
of this movie it was just like let that
make like an over four-hour movie
um but oddly enough I can see that
because there seems for example when uh
there's a scene where like that the
Avengers aren't getting along and they
sort of have the easy out there there's
a scene there in the room and they're
all sort of arguing stuff like that
Romero thing in myself once sort of it's
like yeah was set up a nut-nut to this
degree this almost seems a little rushed
and then there's another scene uh you
know Captain America finally comes up
and he shouting orders and people are
following him I'm everything well
there's never really assume were it's
like yes let's follow him the leader I'm
behind him I'm totally let's go you know
it's just sort of ok he's barking orders
now and we'll follow it and he does it
ok but there was no hey here's where
he's the hero now like a lot of them I
was thinking like lure the Rings and a
Narnia both they have that problem too
with their main with Aragorn and uh
William I never thought they'd have that
you know yes I follow you there's still
nothing happened
you know sigh stuff like that little
things like that you know or Loki who
just wants to take over the world and
it's where these creatures sort of come
from is a little vague and why heats or
wants to take over the world is a little
vague and stuff so what what I think is
something is really changing you know
like you know changing the playing field
in terms of like a genre I do actually
think when you like you're not like
the Dark Knight you know what's that but
well that's about anarchy that's about
uh you know the discovering you know who
you are and where you're going and you
know at what point do you you know it is
it good to be the sign it's good to be
another side and the definition of good
and evil and you know sort of stuff I
guess in some way comic books do talk
about by that just took it to a new
grisly nature and sir this uncomfortable
nature you know the Heath Ledger
performance was so good and you know the
way it shot this it still there's a bad
guy take over the world
superhero stop them you know and for
that it's great and it's done
wonderfully I just from a storytelling
point of view I didn't see anything that
new with the exception of the build-up
to it but again for what this is it's
wonderful it's a great action flick in
the last half-hour 45 minutes uh you'll
be laughing you'll be cheering you'll be
you know rooting for them and you'll be
The Hulk and some great scenes finally
we get some good Hulk scenes gadot's
we've had two movies I mean one
god-awful one just merely okay uh you
know that's the other thing up the one
last thing I'll talk about because a lot
of people are talking about well how's
uh Ruffalo replacing Edward Norton
suppress and I really like Aaron Norton
I think Ruffalo is better actually I
like the way he plays and he plays very
differently he plays and where Edward
Norton was sort of the smart guy and
he's trying to figure stuff out but he's
trying to keep his head and stuff
Ruffalo plays it very much like a person
who's really been through hell and he
just looks like he's been through just
this like he's been through a war or
something but he's finally found that
peace a he's just trying to keep that
peace and keep that inner quiet and
stuff even when people are trying to
sort of like Stark is constantly trying
to egg them on asia's again no you
they won't work and blah blah blah but
you can you can tell he's really been
through a lot too and it was a very well
done performance very different uh you
know it was a very different take and I
really liked it I liked his take on it a
lot everyone else Scarlett Johansson is
great they all have like you know the
set outside even some of these side
characters you don't even you barely
know I mean get set up and get
personality and stuff like that so it's
it's a very for a film like this like I
said it's very well done very nicely put
together it's I see why people are
calling it great and epic and stuff like
that and you should you really should
like I said that this is the critical
side of me that says yes this is very
very very very good uh for me personally
it's like right what if this next man I
wide this in you know in something else
I grew up with but I just I didn't grow
up with Avengers that much so I'm not
quite on the you know that this is the
perfect movie boat but it is a very
nicely done good film probably just
start repeating myself right now the in
terms of who liked it
Avengers fans comic-book fans action
movie fans comedy fans will probably get
a big kick out of it in terms of people
who wouldn't like it
I don't think again a lot of people I
know that saw Dark Knight you know who
don't like comic book movie got into him
they got into how grisly was and how
real and grim it was uh I don't know if
this is a movie like that where even if
you don't like comic books like this
will change you like this will be you
know sort of that tipping board does
something make you like cuz it just it
is silly I mean you just like the gosh
it's away it's silly but it's very
entertaining and I don't think anyone
that goes in not why does the accountant
book movie is gonna like this I mean
it's it's very much a comic book movie
and it's winds in it and it loves it and
it really enjoys the fact that that's
what it is but still takes its audience
seriously uh and has some really strong
writing with the humor on this I mean
really strong writing
and good character interactions so I
really liked I thought was a lot of fun
you've heard everybody praise the hell
out of it it's a good flick I mean go
check it out it lot of money through and
for the effects everything's pretty good
so nothing too much else to report cuz
everybody's already said it already so
good film that's all I got
take care